there are clear signs of just how
traumatic it must have been there's
burnt out windows smashed glass evidence
that people were trying to escape and
indeed videos on Chinese social media
show people hanging out of the windows
at one person at least lowering
themselves down on a bed sheet jumping
onto a roof uh just below the hospital
itself and we have more detail as to how
many people have lost their lives 29
people we Now understand died in that
fire and that's despite authorities
saying that they actually put the fire
out within half an hour we also
understand a little bit more about how
the fire broke out apparently the
authorities say there was renovation
Works going on in the building and that
a spark from some of that work hit some
flammable material and the fire spread
and Authority said that they have
arrested 12 people in connection to what
happened some from the hospital
Administration and some from the
building Works team as well there will
be questions about how this was able to
happen and it is absolutely notable that
the Beijing authorities have said
they're launching a big investigation
into fire safety and Care Homes and
skyscrapers as well so I think a sense
from the authorities that there could be
a bit of a a reckoning and certainly
public questions about these public
safety measures and how far they were
being followed or adhered to here at
this Hospital